in this video we're going to talk about
the real cause of headaches in migraines
this is very important and very valuable
because this video is actually worth
thirty 1 billion dollars and that's the
amount of money that's spent on
headaches every single year it's crazy
if you look up the cause of headaches
you'll normally see it's an unknown
cause it's very complex it's very
mysterious and it's usually coming from
anxiety or depression that's actually
not the case the cause of headaches is
very simple when you look at the whole
body I think the confusion is when
people get pain in their head they think
the problem is in your head
headaches are does not cut the source of
headaches do not come from your head
usually maybe 1% of the time so one of
the first things you want to do with a
headache or a migraine and by the way a
migraine is just a more severe headache
where it can involve a sensitivity to
light nauseousness and vomiting all
right get a history find out is there
any pattern involved in these headaches
maybe it's connected to your sinuses
because the pressure well that's a
pretty no-brainer then this would be the
cause or maybe it's connected to your
menstrual period which every month you
get a headache
we just isolated the root cause or maybe
it was after an injury or after you
drank alcohol last night had a hangover
or when you stopped drinking caffeine
and you got caffeine withdrawals or
maybe it was an allergy so you want to
get a history to get a clue of what's
causing these headaches but 90% of all
headaches are coming from the gall
bladder all right if you don't believe
me and you have a headache right now all
you have to do is take your hands and
press over the gall bladder which is
right down here underneath the right rib
cage and just press in and go in a
little bit at this angle and hold this
for two minutes if your headaches clear
up then we know it's gallbladder and
this is food related it's many times
when you eat too many nuts or peanut
butter when you try to eat healthier
that will trigger the gallbladder a lot
of times it could be junk food or fatty
foods but that gallbladder triggers a
nerve right underneath your diaphragm
that's called the phrenic nerve
that goes right up through to the right
shoulder and up to the head and also the
gallbladder Meridian in Chinese medicine
goes all up to the top of your head all
the way through here but it also goes on
the left side too depending on if you
have a digestive issue so 90 percent of
the time it's going to be gallbladder
related and you just need to change your
eating five percent of time it's going
to be coming from a nerve pinch in your
neck of course when you go to the
chiropractor when you get adjusted and
align that neck and head it goes away we
know it's coming from a pinched nerve
but let's say it keeps coming back over
and over and over then we know there's
some other cause I personally had
headaches for 12 years and I didn't know
what they were until I found out it was
my gallbladder
it wasn't my neck because I had probably
thousand adjustments and it just kept
coming back over and over and over and
over so when you try to solve the wrong
problem and it keeps coming back then we
have the wrong problem okay
2% of the time it's the sinuses right
well that's pretty easy because you have
a sinus congestion it could be back into
the the station choose back into the
back of the throat up to the ears and
that pressure will definitely cause a
headache and then you just want to do
things to help your sinuses I like to
recommend the kale shake in the morning
for because the high vitamin A you can
go to my website and download the recipe
also you can do consume radishes
radishes are really good to pull mucus
out of the body and the sinuses and that
will clear up the sinuses and then we
have the menstrual cycle so if you get a
headache that time of the month then we
needed to support the ovaries with some
type of natural remedy to help the
headaches only 1% of time is it going to
be coming from these things right here
from an old injury to the head that
could be the source of a headache a
tumor which is very very rare and of
course if you have exhausted all the
most common ones then you can actually
get some testing to see is it really
headache the problem is I had people
I've had people come in and they've
spent thousands and thousands of dollars
with testing when this is so rare to
look for a tumor and they never found
it's just a waste of money if you do
something very simple and you rule out
the cause of it you saved a lot of money
okay infection meningitis if you have a
fever and you feel tired it could be an
infection causing your headaches
don't rule that out that's especially if
you have a skin reaction on your body
and it could be an allergy to something
it could be a food allergy
I've had people have headaches after
eating gluten which is the protein wheat
or maybe milk or some other allergy that
could be causing triggering the
headaches so that's mainly going to be
food-related or it could be in viruses
'''l related caffeine withdrawal we've
talked about that or a hangover so
that's the order of sequence of most
common - least common causes of
headaches I hope this helped if it's
helped you please make a comment below
on this video
and I'll see you in the next video